hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video heute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut ich habe heute
folgendes vor ihr habt auch an den schon
gelesen ich habe also tatsächlich es
gibt ja auf youtube schon so viele
misery box unboxing und ich hatte auch
mal wieder block eins zu machen halt
irgendwie ich wollte so ein bisschen was
ausgefallenes haben und ursprünglich
wollte ich eigentlich von dieser seite
mystery boxes eine apple mit box
bestellen hier kann man für 49 dollar 99
sonne box bestellen und krieg dann in
der box eine von diesen sachen also wenn
es gut läuft ein iphone wenn es schlecht
läuft ein iphone charger bevor ich da
ist irgendwie vier boxen oder sowie
stelle wollte ich euch erstmal fragen
soll ich das machen hat irgendwie von
euch erfahrungen damit ist das absolute
abzocke oder meint ihr alex mache
einfach mal gucken was passiert weil ich
ich wird das halt schon machen
des weiteren bin ich dann allerdings auf
real kennt man in dieser supermarkt die
verkaufen auch mystery boxen paket 10
bis 30 teile überraschungspaket querbeet
neuware retouren wahres ich habe mir
gedacht alter was kann denn da drin sein
bei real ist ein supermarkt also leute
was ich unbedingt auch sagen muss die
sachen stammen zwar von real de ich
denke aber sie kommen nicht direkt von
real das ist irgendwie einfach so einen
real marktplatz wo jeder händler seine
produkte auch verkaufen kann also so
habe ich das jetzt festgestellt ich
dachte ursprünglich das alles halt
retouren ware von dem supermarkt reales
ja schon selbst
ich fand das sehr interessant und habe
dann einfach mal eingekauft wir haben
eine kiste für 30 euro und drei kisten
für 10 euro und wir sind auch heute
morgen angekommen
so sieht das ganze aus großes paket ist
jetzt nicht sonderlich schwer oder so
ich würde mal so schätzen 78 kilo und
die aufgabe für das heutige video
besteht jetzt darin die auszupacken
letzte oder wir starten einfach nur mit
der oberen mir
also ich hab wirklich absolut keinen
plan was mich jetzt hier erwartet das
kann eigentlich alles sein
es können lebensmittel sein wobei ich
das glaube ich nicht denke weil es ich
weiß nicht ob man einfach so
lebensmittel verschicken kann anhalt
welche die nicht schnell ablaufen was
schauen ob sich die 60 euro lohnt ich
habe keinen plan welche von denen die
für 30 euro war aber die kommt zu 100
prozent von real de ja
fangen wir mal mit der ersten box an ich
hoffe dass es halt nicht so ein müll wie
wir hatten ja schon so oft zu amazon box
und wirklich nur schrott drin war
luftballons party ballon 25 stück in
orange ok ja was kostet so war es in
euro keine ahnung hier haben wir das
geht ja schon super los dass hier sieht
mir aus wieso helium luftballons als
gitarre also ich muss sagen wir haben
hier in unserer stadt keinen real aber
es gibt ja schon relativ viele real
märkte in deutschland oder und da gibt
es auch lebensmittel verkaufen doch
eigentlich oder haben hier auch noch so
riesenspieler abteilung und ich weiss
ich glaube ich war ein oder zwei mal in
meinem leben in so einem ding hiermit
kann ich auf jeden fall bis jetzt nur
relativ wenig anfangen
aber wir haben ja auch noch hüte das
sieht aus wie sonne schon eingerissen
ist dass ein chinesischer gut das könnte
vielleicht seine geburtstagsgäste sein
oder so ja super so was habe ich mir
schon immer mal gewünscht was ich weiß
nicht mal für was sowas gut sein soll
hier haben wir dann auch eine
cowboy haucap sohn ein kokon schleife
für die haare wie für die mädels und in
dem paket ist dann natürlich noch ein
paket film was okay 12345 ja tatsächlich
wir haben hier für mich als ich hoffe
mal also hier muss ich sagen die
qualität ist neu ist das sind so so
frauen frauen schade schals was ist denn
jetzt die mehrzahl von stahl ein schal
zwei schale zahlen lassen wir das ich
würde jetzt einfach mal behaupten ein so
einen schal kostet doch bestimmt 345
euro oder also hiermit herzlich als sie
zehn euro theoretisch wieder raus auch
wenn ich die abgrundtief hässlich finde
außerdem hier den kann ich vielleicht
meine mama schenken und sehen hier
meiner oma und den hier meine tante ich
selber kann damit auch nichts anfangen
also die erste kiste war eigentlich von
arch ich hoffe mal das war eine zehn
euro küste jetzt gehts weiter
[Musik]
hey was sind das für sparkurs alter ist
das ist das ein witz oder was hier ist
einfach genau das gleiche drin
wollt ihr mich verarschen also irgendwas
machen aggressiv jetzt hat mystery box
10 bis 30 teile überraschungspaket
querbeet neuware
ich hoffe für die jetzt mal dass in dem
nächsten was anderes drin ist wobei ich
ein ganz schlechtes gefühl hab weil wenn
im 2 schon das einmal was für idioten
aber 5
wie sieht jetzt ein bisschen anders aus
die letzte hürde sei einfach nichts hier
was anders muss auch etwas anderes sein
das ist genau
das ist doch nicht so schlecht dass das
ist
mir tut das richtig leid man ich es sind
einfach genau das ist jetzt mal andere
leute mir tut das so leitner
ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen ich
versuche immer irgendwie möglichst
cooles video hinzubekommen und das ist
auch immer nicht wenig aufwand sich
irgendwas rauszusuchen was man dann
wieder bestellt das kostet auch immer
wieder geld meint das waren jetzt mal
einfach 16 keine ahnung warum in der
kiste für 30 euro genauso viel müll war
er für zehn euro
das hat auch überhaupt keine bewertung
hier das ding ich weiß nicht was das was
das soll ich schickte auf jeden fall
warne beschwerden oder so ich kann euch
das absolut nicht empfehlen zu bestellen
wenn ich eine mystery box bestellten bat
ich glaube dass da immer was anderes
drin ist ja es hat ja ein grund dass ich
vier verschiedene bestelle und ich bin
jetzt auch super traurig darüber weil
ich ja auch irgendwie ein cooles video
machen möchte wo ich euch was cooles
zeit und so und dann überlegt man jetzt
wieder lohnt sich das überhaupt das
hochzuladen weil ist es halt einfach nur
scheiße gewesen und an sich ist das
video jetzt auch blöd und ich bin
wirklich sehr oft zurzeit sodann bei den
videos und denke mir okay ist das jetzt
überhaupt cool genug du willst
eigentlich zu unboxing und so machen und
was machen wir eigentlich immer spaß
wenn die sachen alkohol sind aber sowas
ja ich hatte das in letzter zeit hat
jetzt schon öfter dass da einfach nur
das ist halt nicht cool geworden ist das
video so dass sich auch offen und
ehrlich ein drei mal habe ich dann schon
gar nicht hochgeladen ich dachte jetzt
dass das mal wieder was cooles wird ja
vielleicht kann man das ja verstehen
oder halt auch nicht also es tut mir
leid wenn jetzt halt wieder leute so auf
das video geklickt haben und sich dachte
bestimmt richtig nice realen misery box
zeugs und dann ist halt ich weiß nicht
vielleicht leicht das video mal wieder
hoch ich habe jetzt am ende was dazu
gesagt ihr könnt ja mal vielleicht da
auch was in die kommentare zu schreiben
oder so tut mir so leid das ist wie es
jetzt gelaufen ist ich würde auf jeden
fall sehr gerne diese apple mystery
boxen bestellen wenn ihr da auch lust
habt können das ja mal schreiben ich
hoffe das wird dann mal wieder was cool
ist und das war's dann leider schon
wieder dass euch das video gefällt kann
ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht sagen
wir sehen uns dann montag oder so wieder
am montag in mainz